we've had the International posters come  out which really I was so geeked about  but when the IMAX poster came out I was  like I'm an IMAX that's so rad the sound  is what usually blows my mind in the  IMAX theatre and it's just huge and this  movie's huge and it's beautiful  the best way to describe it to you  people at home is if you look at this  interview on your computer step back  from it and then just smash your face  right into the computer just press your  nose up against it and then that's the  experience and IMAX it's just in your  face I love that IMAX screen right I was  on the edge of my seat from the start  the visual effects in this is something  I've never seen before and this at a  level one I think the bigger the better  [Music]  you see my movie it's a documentary  called Thor Ragnarok  [Music]